(upbeat music)
- [Evan] We just discovered something.
Timo lost his first two teeth.
Look at the bottom.
Aww, he's missing his two
baby teeth, he's growing up.
What do you think Nina?
- We have to find your teeth.
- [Evan] Your guy is growing up.
- That's why you're buff today, huh?
Is that why?
You're good.
- [Evan] What do you think Nina?
What's your message?
- There's no message.
- [Evan] There's no message?
- No.
- [Evan] That's it?
- Just keep, I don't know.
You, my grown up boy now.
You're not a puppy anymore.
- [Evan] We need a message, Nina.
- I don't know, what's a message?
- [Evan] Give us something
solid to end this video.
- I don't know (laughs).
I don't know, just you do it.
You give a message, I don't know.
- [Evan] The message is love
your, look how cute he is.
The message is look at
the cute dog (laughs).
And believe.
(laughing)
Have a great weekend, guys.
- You are so cute, oh my
goodness, you're so cutie.
(whooshing)